hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers who
wants to start a coffee shop that
donates a dollar from every coffee sale
to support a local hospital and one of
my advice on how to get started doesn't
have the money to launch the business
and needed some help so to help with
this question I think the first thing
that you need to think about for your
business is you need to get to the
survival point so it's great to be able
to support charity and I'm a big
believer in you know giving back to the
community for us we do a lot of work
with an organization called Kiva that
we've helped raise over fifty thousand
dollars for but the thing is your
business you have to make sure that it's
going to be around for long term so that
you're going to be able to help a lot
more people through your company so you
have to be able to get your company to
you know survival point where you're
able to pay your bills you know live the
lifestyle that you're you know going
after and then make extra money that you
can hopefully you know give back to the
charity so if you're starting a business
that's all around the charity not that
it's a bad idea but you're less likely
to be able to hit the success and have a
big impact that I assume you're try to
have so if you're starting a business
and half the money goes to the charity
for example and you're not able to build
your business to that survival point
then if you closed down in three months
how much of an impact have you had on
that charity where if you were to build
a business and maybe give a little less
at the start still have it as part of
your marketing message as part of your
core beliefs and you hire people around
you know who want to help charities as
well but make sure that you have enough
at the end of the day to keep that
business going and pay everybody and
then as you start to build your business
you able to give a lot more back to
charity so people will work with you and
will bark from you because of the
charity aspect they might go you know a
little bit further because you work with
charity they might support a little bit
higher price because you work with
charity but it's not overwhelming you
still have to have a business model as
you know run a really good business have
great coffee have
service and I just want to make sure
that you have your systems in place so
that you're providing that quality
service and you're able to get past that
survival point so you can have a much
bigger impact when you are giving back
to to the charities that you believe in
so that's kind of number one to start
with if you you know don't have enough
money to get the company started what I
would try to do is partner up with the
local retail shop and just take over a
little part of their store and say can I
come in and you know sell my coffee and
you know baked goods on you know
whatever day of the week or maybe it's
everyday but just a small section of the
shop and you might have to pay a little
bit of that they might see it as value I
to their customers so they won't charge
you or they could take a percentage of
the profit that comes in but you don't
have to start the business with your own
location because that can be really
expensive and you'll make a lot of
mistakes so it's better to learn in the
low risk low cost way and as you start
to understand how to run this store then
you'll be better equipped to launch your
own store so I try to start with you
know within a local retail owner learn
the ins and outs try to learn from that
order to how they run their business and
you know dealing with staff and dealing
with just a retail operation start you
know small scale and then you can also
test the location so you know retail
location is huge you can figure out
pretty low risk if that location is
going to work for you or not and you
start to build your following and if it
is a good location and you're building a
following and you are certain to make
money then it's going to make sense to
go open up your own store and you'll
have the capital to be able to do it so
hopefully that helps I love to hear you
guys it to think if you want to leave a
comment under the video and if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up but
love seeing those come in so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you